while we were all enjoying our
Thanksgiving dinners with friends and
family former Minneapolis Police Officer
Derek chovin was getting stabbed nearly
to death in prison by another inmate
chovin is in prison because our cowardly
justice system sacrificed him to the Mob
as a scapegoat for the death of a career
criminal whose death was actually caused
primarily by his resisting arrest after
having ingested a fatal dose of fenel
chovin is currently serving 20 years in
prison
for second deegree murder a crime that
no reasonable person actually thinks
that he committed he's also serving
another simultaneous 20-year sentence
for civil rights violations whatever
that means in fact though he is in
prison because over the past half
century our Elite institutions have
adopted the racially tinged
liberationist ideology of avowed
marxists such as Angela Davis Derek Bell
Kimberly Crenshaw and terrorists such
such as Huey Newton and Eldridge cleav
whose Black Liberation movement was so
lazily rebranded in recent years that
they even kept the same initialism
BLM chovin spends much of his time in
solitary confinement which is liable to
drive him insane if he isn't insane
already but the solitary confinement is
for his own safety and he clearly isn't
spending enough time there as the
weekend's attack shows meanwhile the
rest of us even though those of us who
vocally opposed BLM in those early days
when it was unfashionable even on the
right when squishes like Mitt Romney
were marching with the terror supporting
radicals even many of us have forgotten
about officer chovin and that will
likely Remain the case until another
inmate succeeds at murdering him we will
forget about him because one our
attention spans are short but two more
so we will forget about him because the
reality of the Injustice the reality
that we in our supposedly exemplary
nation of laws sacrificed a man to the
Mob and that reality is just too much to
bear I'm Michael nlls this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show today's your
last shot at the best deal of the Year
get
50% off dailywire plus annual
memberships now is the time to join for
adree uncensored content from all of
your favorite hosts the best deal of the
year ends today get it now at
dailywire.com
subscribe AI robots are taking all of
our jobs pretty soon when you subscribe
to the dailywire you will be able to see
a robot that looks just like me uh
recite talking points that it itself
wrote while I can go off and pursue my
real passion which is selling cigar uh
we'll get to that in just a moment first
though I know already what's happening I
know already at the leftwing groups
whose job it is to watch our shows and
fact check us and then try to get us all
fired uh which is jokes on them because
we're going to be replaced by robots in
about 6 months so good luck firing us
but I know what they're doing right now
they're sitting there and they're saying
Michael nolles he just spread false
information we're going to write to News
Guard we are going to write to all of
the leftwing groups that partner with
the social media companies to curtail
the amount of information that can go
around the Public Square we're going to
write to them and say you got to take
this show off the air it's
misinformation why
because this has already been fact
checked here's what the fact checks say
uh this is from the Associated Press
claim a new autopsy report for George
Floyd has been released in 2023
revealing he died from a drug overdose
not from the actions of arresting
Minneapolis police officers now I want
to put a pause right here that is not
actually the claim that I or many other
conservatives are making with regard to
George Floyd and officer
chovin not we're not saying it it
necessarily was a new autopsy report
released in 2023 we're not necessarily
saying that the police officers had
absolutely nothing to do with the
circumstances of his death this is what
they do the libs is they lie by
exaggerating or outright lying about the
points that we're making and mix it in
with the true points that we're making
the true point being that George Floyd
was not killed primarily he did not die
primarily from officer chovin and his
knee or whatever here's how the AP
assesses that supposed claim false
social media user users are sharing a
page from the 20page autopsy report that
was publicly released by The hennipin
County Medical Examiner office in full
on June 3rd 2020 it has not been changed
since okay who what's the original say
while the page says that George Floyd
had Fentanyl and methamphetamine in his
system and did not have life-threatening
injuries the full report
concludes that Floyd died from
cardiopulmonary arrest not an overdose
hold on wait what hold on there so
you're admitting the AP the libs are
admitting here that the autopsy the
original
autopsy says that Floyd had Fentanyl and
methamphetamine in his system a lethal
dose of fentanyl by the way I noticed
the AP fact check leaves that one out a
lethal dose of fentanyl in his system
the AP further admits that the autopsy
says that George Floyd did not have any
life-threatening
injuries but the full report concludes
that Floyd died from cardiopulmonary
arrest not an overdose hold on why what
they took not an overdose out of the
quotation marks so the quote from the
autopsy is that he died from
cardiopulmonary arrest none of us
disputes that what is cardiopulmonary
arrest his heart and his lungs stopped
that's what that means it's a fancy way
of saying that yeah his heart and his
lungs stopped that's true now let me ask
you what what you would conclude as a
reasonable person if you know that
officer chauvin's kneee did not cause
any life-threatening
injuries to George Floyd's body if you
know that George Floyd had a lethal dose
of an especially lethal drug in his
system then what would you say is most
likely to be the primary cause of his
heart and lungs
stopping would you say that the primary
cause would be a police officer
restraining him or would you say the
primary cause would be his resisting
arrest for a very long time and the
extremely lethal dose of drugs in his
body what just you're a reasonable
person what would you say is the most
likely primary cause of his death it's
not complicated at all they go on I mean
this this so silly this this fact check
goes on they say no well look it just
doesn't there's nothing new here it just
doesn't they don't say just because
there was no evidence of
life-threatening injuries on the body it
doesn't mean that you know like like
he that chovin isn't totally responsible
and yeah I mean that's actually what
they actually say that there they
say the fact that no major bruising or
damage to the muscles cartilage or bones
and the neck was found as indicated
under the phrase no life-threatening
injuries identified in the autopsy does
not mean that asfixia did not occur only
that there are no signs of it on the
body okay hey it doesn't mean that our
preconceived narrative that has been
disproven time and time again at every
it doesn't mean that it's ultimately not
true it just means there's no sign of it
being true that's what they're saying
and as a result of this it's it's really
distressing because I'm I'm not I don't
I don't follow police regulations all
that closely I don't know the ins and
outs of the Minneapolis police code book
but I do have a a modum of Common
Sense and it seems clear to me the
reason that Derrik schen is in prison
for murder for murder for goodness sakes
is because he was the scapegoat and
because our cowardly criminal justice
system was afraid of the mob that's
clearly it and a consequence of that is
you've
discouraged any sensible person from
joining the police force anywhere in the
certainly anywhere in a blue State you
join the police force because you want
to serve your your community and you're
willing to take a job that's very
difficult that doesn't pay very well
it's very dangerous and you're willing
to do that to serve your community
that's a noble thing to do and and then
you find out that if you if if you
transgress the leftwing mob you're going
to be potentially thrown in prison and
then maybe stabbed to death in prison
because the media dishonestly portrayed
you as a a racist or a this or a thatst
or an otherwise evil person why would
you do it so as a consequence of this
not only are we seeing Injustice being
faced by one man in particular Derek
Chauvin who very likely will just be
killed in
prison but a political consequence for
all of us is you're going to see a
further breakdown of law order because
the liberal establishment is going to
cynically but conveniently tactically
take the side of criminals over the side
of Law and Order over the side of th
those who protect the community and so
crime rights are going to Skyrocket
property crimes are going to Skyrocket
violent crimes are going to Skyrocket
and our political order is going to
continue to fray not great not great not
just for anyone
involved
now speaking of the breakdown of Law and
Order and former police officers New
York city mayor Eric Adams he's a former
cop he has just been accused of sexually
assaulting a
woman 30 years
ago seems like a meaningful detail there
he's accused of sexually assaulting a
woman I obviously believe we should take
all such accusation seriously but hold
on 30 years ago and now the woman is
suing him for $5 million wow boy did she
just fall into a coma for 30 years she
forgot that this terrible crime occurred
she didn't she didn't ask for justice 30
years ago then as Eric Adams started to
rise through the political ranks she
never decided to bring any charge
against him never decided to sue him in
any sort of civil court then he gets
elected mayor of New York City years ago
at this point oh no even then we're not
going to I'm not interested this man
raped me but I'm not I'm not going to
even mention it to anyone and then
there's a New York City law a New York
law it's called the adult survivors act
which is about to expire that says that
essentially you can sue someone for
sexual crimes without any statute of
limitations and all of a sudden this
woman who says Eric Adams sexually
assaulted her in '93 she's seeking $5
million at the time Adams was a cop uh
the accuser was also a city worker
according to the New York Post what's my
take on this my take on this
is Eric Adams seriously needs to get the
lesson to stop criticizing Mass
migration you know this guy he didn't
figure it out he thought that because he
was a Democrat he a liberal Democrat
that he was protected no one was going
to do to Eric Adams what they did to say
Donald Trump they're not they're not
going to use the criminal justice system
to Railroad this guy as a political
persecution no no way well except Eric
Adams has broken from the Democratic
party in a major way in recent months on
the issue of mass migration and he's
come out and he said this migrant crisis
is going to destroy New York City if Joe
Biden doesn't do something about it Eric
Adams was criticizing not just the
policy broadly he was criticizing the
White House he was criticizing the
people who were supposed to be enforcing
the law and then what happened then all
of a
sudden the feds start investigating Eric
Adams because he took a donation from a
guy who was on the board of a thing that
involved a Turkish guy or something
we're talking about a very small
political donation on top of that the
minute I saw that I said oh you better
he better stop criticizing Mass
migration and at a broader level he
better stop criticizing the powers that
be that's what this is really about the
powers that be and one of their most
cherished policies namely open
borders so he starts to get investigated
what happens is I don't want to sound
like I'm a conspiracy theory tinfoil hat
guy but days not even it might have been
one or two days after this investigation
was announced Eric Adams says he's
cancelling a meeting at the White House
to discuss the migration crisis you can
read about that in the mainstream press
so you don't need to make 10,000 leaps
of logic it was right
there Mass migration is destroying
America it's destroying New York City in
particular Joe Biden's got to stop this
I'm going to have a meeting with the
White House to stop Mass
migration Eric Adams getting
investigated by the feds 5 seconds later
okay I'm not going to have my meeting
anymore I'm I'll cut it out and then he
gets hit with this obviously ridiculous
sexual
assault lawsuit clearly a money grab
Adams for hisport is saying I've never
met this woman if I did ever meet this
woman I certainly have no memory of
it I I do believe I'll break with some
right- wiers who dismiss all of these
suits out of hand I do think some of
them are legit I am inclined to to uh
believe women when they make these
claims I'm not inclined to believe women
when they make these claims 30 years
later when they stand to make $5 million
and when we're living in in in an age
where men are presumed guilty until
proven innocent now speaking of democrat
politicians Joe Biden has a novel theory
on how war broke out in the Middle East
did you know we know the
timeline October 7th Hamas leads a Pome
against Jews in Israel takes a bunch of
hostages kills well over a thousand
civilians rapes kills pillages and burns
horrific terror attack then state of
Israel responds by bombing
Gaza by in in leading a ground Invasion
into
Gaza then there's a ceasefire the
ceasefire seems to be going okay as of
the Airing of this show today Hamas
releasing some of the hostages in
exchange for a temporary ceasefire from
Israel Joe Biden says no no what that
timeline is missing is why Hamas had the
terror attack in the first place and the
reason is you see no one knows this Joe
Biden was about to bring peace to the
Middle East I cannot prove what I'm
about to say but I believe one of the
reasons why Hamas struck when they did
was they knew that I was working very
closely with the Saudis and others in
the region to bring peace to the region
by having recognition of Israel and
Israel's right to exist you may recall
when we did the G20 about a little while
ago I was able to get a resolution a a
statement passed through there saying
we're going to build a railroad from
Riad all the way through the Middle East
into into Saudi Arabia Israel Etc and
all the way up to Europe not the not the
railroad but it would be an underground
Pipeline and then Railroad
can you pause it right there for a
second hold on before he goes on I just
want to make clear he says he was going
to build a railroad from Riad all the
way to Saudi
Arabia it isn't Riad is that how where
would that wouldn't that railroad just
be kind of like a circular it'd be he
doesn't I think he's a little well I
think we all know Joe Biden is a little
bit
confused as to how the geopolitics of
the Middle East Works keep going yes
there's overwhelming interest and I
think most Arab Nations know it in
coordinating with one another to change
the dynamic in their region for longer
term peace and uh that is uh what I'm
going to continue to work on okay now
people are they're not going to believe
it they're not going to know but
actually I was about to bring peace to
the Middle
East that's why people aren't going to
believe it but that's what what it
was that's the ticket yeah that's the
ticket Donald Trump
the the the last
president brought peace to the Middle
East there were no new Middle Eastern
Wars dragging the United States into
further conflict that broke out under
his watch actually what they got was a
peace deal between Saudi Arabia and
Israel actually what they got was the
Abraham Accords actually what they got
was relative peace in the Middle East
actually what they got was Isis was
eliminated actually what they got was
Iran was on the its heels actually what
they got was Syria was on its heels
actually what they got was
everyone stayed real quiet and real
cautious because no one knew what Trump
was going to do was Trump the biggest
Dove ever didn't want to be involved in
any wars or was Trump the craziest war
hawk in the world who was going to drop
the Moab and assassinate top generals
left and
right he was both that's was was Donald
Trump the leader of the anti- war party
an opponent of the uni party in
Washington DC those warmongering
neoconservatives Donald Trump was going
to be a new breath of fresh air Donald
Trump a republican attacking George W
bush for starting wars in the Middle
East Donald Trump saying I want no new
Wars was he going to be that guy or was
Donald Trump going to be the guy who
appointed John Bolton as his National
Security adviser John Bolton who has
wanted to bomb Iran since he was in the
womb who was Donald Trump he was both he
was unpredictable and his foreign policy
led to relative peace in the Middle East
Joe
Biden has has led to an outbreak of War
all over the place in Eastern Europe in
the Middle East worst outbreaks of war
in either of those places in a long time
and and so how does Biden explain it
Biden I was just in New York over the
weekend Biden is like I think Family Guy
made this point once Biden is like an
Italian guy in a hypothetical situation
now listen here you know listen if I had
been there if I had been there in the
situation you're describing oh what I
would have done you wouldn't believe
what I would have done I would have done
this that and the other thing but it's
always
hypothetical what did you do it has to
be hypothetical for Biden because he's
failed it doesn't have to be
hypothetical for Trump because he did it
yes but uh listen here fellas I can't do
a I can't do a New York Italian Joe
Biden listen if I people aren't going to
believe it but what I would have done
what I come on Jack what I would have
what would have done had I been able to
do the thing that I wanted to do in the
M I would have brought total peace in
the Middle East listen listen Jack if my
aunt had testical she have been my uncle
you know listen here pal if my Grandma
had Wheels should be a wagon all right
jack exactly exactly in the hypothetical
World in which the premises of the left
are correct then things would work out
peachy but the world is different from
the way the libs believe the world is
and that's why the conservative policy
works a lot better this is it it's your
final day to save on the best deals of
the Year daily wire plus annual
memberships are 50 5% off do not miss
this opportunity to join at the lowest
price of the year dailywire plus gives
you unlimited access to all of the
exclusive adree uncensored content from
all of us along with OnDemand access to
the ground breaking entertainment and
eye openening documentaries that are
reshaping the cultural landscape plus
your daily wire Plus Membership unlocks
the daily wires New Kids Entertainment
app bent key the absolute best thing I
can say to you as a parent Ben key is I
let my kids watch it get up to 40 4% off
all Germany's razor products don't miss
out on all of the deals inside the
dailywire Black Friday gift guide shop
the deals now at dailywire.com Black
Friday speaking of Joe Biden and Holy
Wars I guess Joe Biden gave a
Thanksgiving Proclamation this year as
the presidents usually do but he left an
important person out of it uh that would
be
God and thanks
Thanksgiving Joe Biden in his
Proclamation did not give thanks
to the person to whom the thanks is
supposed to be given in the very holiday
of Thanksgiving he forgot the big
guy when the Thanksgiving holiday was
formally instituted that was 1863 it was
done by Abraham Lincoln there there were
obviously many other uh official and
semiofficial observances of Thanksgiving
prior to Lincoln but Lincoln inaugurates
the the um holiday as we know it today
and what does Lincoln say he says we're
going to set apart and observe the last
Thursday of November quot as a day of
Thanksgiving and praise to our
beneficent father who dwelleth in the
heavens even during the Civil War
Abraham Lincoln gives thanks to God he
says no human Council hath devised nor
hath any mortal hand worked out these
great things they are the gracious gifts
of the most high God who while dealing
with us in anger for our sins hath
nevertheless remembered Mercy obviously
uh George Washington recognizes
Thanksgiving obviously Thanksgiving goes
all the way back to the pilgrims who
came over to this country on the
Mayflower uh the puffing of which is a
wonderful way to observe the
Thanksgiving holiday and every day of
the year but I
digress by my count only two presidents
in American history ever have given a
Thanksgiving
Proclamation that omitted God to whom we
owee thanks that would be Joe Biden and
Barack
Obama they're the only two what does
this mean does this mean that it's just
the Democrats have always been the party
against God well implicitly perhaps but
they at least would pay lip service to
God Jimmy Carter certainly acknowledged
God in his Thanksgiving proclamations
Bill Clinton acknowledged God in his
Thanksgiving
proclamations this is a new thing for
Democrat president presidents it's Obama
and then Biden Biden being Barack
Obama's third term what does that mean
it means that liberalism today is
anti-christian you might say liberalism
was always anti-christian that's my view
I think that liberalism from the very
very beginning marked a rebellion
against God and against God's order of
things and against the Christian
religion I think this is beautifully
summed up in John Milton's Paradise Lost
when Satan is down in hell and he says
well it's better to serve it's better to
reign in Hell than to serve in heaven
the mind is its own place and can make a
hell of heaven and Heaven a
hell that that principle of total self-
sovereignty self-ownership
which underlies so much of liberalism
classical and modern is I think
ultimately quite anti-christian anti-god
satanic even yeah I think that but a lot
of people don't think that a lot of
people like liberalism or they say I
like the old liberalism but I don't like
the new liberalism I like the classical
I don't like New Coke I like classic
Coke you know I like classic liberalism
not new but whatever okay some people
like that at the very least you have got
to acknowledge now that liberalism today
and one suspects into the
future is anti-god and the reason it's
anti-god doesn't require a PhD in
theology doesn't require any
delving through any dark conspiracy
theories it's because liberalism
replaces god with a new God and that new
God is the god of self the ability to do
whatever we want it replaces a political
order that that views our role as one of
uh gratitude and loyalty and obligation
to our family to our community to our
country and ultimately to our god a
political order of humility that
recognizes our own fallenness and
Brokenness
and need of one another and ultimately
need of God and our our uh insufficiency
to reconstruct the world the fact that
we were not there when God laid that the
foundations of the earth and that we are
bound by the moral
order it replaces that political order
with one that that says well you can do
whatever you want you're you're
primarily not a creature with loyalty
and humility and obligation but one that
uh is entitled to all sorts of Rights
new rights that you never been conceived
of before whatever rights you can name
you you are perfect just as you are you
you ought to celebrate not humility but
Pride we ought to have whole parades for
Pride actually once considered the queen
of all Vice now it's going to be the the
vice of all queens as Andrew claven says
now we're going to make that the highest
virtue that's what liberalism is today
maybe that's kind of what liberalism
always was I don't know but it's
certainly what it is today don't take my
word for it just look at the actions of
the last two Democrat presidents
speaking of
Thanksgiving it goes even deeper not
only do we cut God out of Thanksgiving
now we cut Thanksgiving out of
Thanksgiving Lowden County Schools this
is this is I think the wealthiest County
in the
country the superintendent of L Lowden
County Schools celebrated Thanksgiving
with a message to families here's what
he wrote ladden County Superintendent
Aaron Spence quote many families will
celebrate
Thanksgiving amid this busyness I hope
you and your loved ones find time during
the Thanksgiving break regardless of
whether you celebrate this holiday or
not to share your
gratitude come
again Thanksgiving now is a sectarian
contoversial holiday only celebrated by
some American citizens what
I I would get it if he said let's say it
were a a Jewish holiday and the Len
County Superintendent says hey to all
the people who celebrate uh you know
happy Jewish holiday I know that a lot
of you are not Jewish and therefore
don't celebrate so I want to just tell
the people who do celebrate you know
have a good time and for the people who
don't you know uh ignore this message
that would make sense because relatively
few people celebrate the Jewish holidays
I I
even sort of get with Christian holidays
I don't really because America was
founded as a Christian Nation quite
explicitly and has been practically a
Christian Nation for all of our history
until very very recently but even then I
could understand you know hey Merry
Christmas and um even if you don't
celebrate I hope you have a good time
too okay I sort of you know if you're
Muslim or Jewish or whatever atheist or
something okay I I almost get that I
still think it's a Christian Nation we
should have public celebrations of the
religion that animates our entire
civilization but okay I sort of get that
but hold
on
Thanksgiving is a is a
national C civil
holiday it's a holiday that celebrates
the
country you're telling me that there are
people in our country right now who
refuse to celebrate the
country the the founding of the country
give a little thanks we said oh it's
nice thank you to our for our country to
or forebears who settled the country and
ultimately to God for all of his
blessings you're telling me there's
people in this country who don't
celebrate that well that's a problem to
me if you're here and you hate the
country and you don't celebrate it you
should
leave at the very least at the very
least you should not be acknowledged by
a public official superintendent
superintendent of a school
district hey if you like America or if
you hate America and you wish death to
America listen whatever it is I hope you
have a great time no it if you wish
death to America you should go away we
don't want you here go go get get
out but whose fault is it this is what
makes the
story most
ironic it is the responsibility of
schools to inculcate civic virtue to
inculcate patriotism to inculcate that
that love of country and and that
attitude of gratitude for your country
the fact that this man is admitting
there are people who don't celebrate
Thanksgiving is an admission of his own
failure and we know that Lowden County
schools has failed quite a lot we know
that the office of the Lowden County
Superintendent has pushed
radical that led to rapes that then the
office of the superintendent covered up
in Lowden County after the story broke
and dily wire broke that story that led
to Ken yunan getting elected in Virginia
okay we know that something is rotten in
Lowden
County but even I am somewhat surprised
at this naked admission of of a
philosophical rot so deep that they say
yeah we're not educating your students
at all in the most basic things
sometimes people think that the most
basic point of education is to teach of
public education is to teach kids
reading writing and arithmetic that's
not true you should do that that's what
public education certainly should entail
but the point of public education this
has been understood going back to the
ancient Greeks going back to Plato all
the way up to the present is to create a
good citizenry that is capable of
conducting itself in within the regime
under which it lives that's the point of
public education this guy says yeah I
blew it though it wasn't an accidental
blowing it let's not forget these
radicals in education for the last 50
years have been trying to undermine the
country that's been the point point and
I guess so they've succeeded at that
they've succeeded at gutting an
essential aspect of a country especially
of a Republic now speaking of
Thanksgiving weekend and
controversies a major controversy that
cropped up that creates a problem for
conservatives and the controversy was
this Dolly Parton showed up to some
football game and she was dressed like a
Dallas Cowboys Cheerleader and she was
wearing her you know short short
and her highly cropped shirt and she did
a performance
and Dolly Parton is 77 years
old and if you look at it she
looks she looks
good but I don't think anyone says Dolly
looks bad they might say she this is
disordered because Dolly Parton is 77
years old 77y old should not be dressed
like this they should not be dancing
like this and so that's disordered but
also Dolly partner is a kind of beloved
figure even conservatives love Dolly
she's not one of these radical leftist
she's sort so what what are
we
conservatives concerned with order and
propriety and etiquette and you know
gracefully aging and family values and
what are we to think about dol's
performance here's my
take Dolly
Parton is a unique case Exempted from
all rules rules of
etiquette and that's that I am not
denying that 77y old women should not
dress like that I am not
denying family values and proper
aesthetic sensibilities and the good the
true and the Beautiful I'm not denying
any of those
things I am not being
hypocritical I think by making an
exception for Dolly
Parton in fact I think I'm artic ulating
a much more conservative point which is
that exceptions prove
rules and rules have exceptions that's
the way it works this is
true in politics and philosophy and
theology modern Libs want everything to
be really clear and have really clinical
regimented rules so that you can
understand the universe in five bullet
point manifestos on the back of a napkin
nope that's not how it works and Dolly
Parton one of the other great
contributions among many that she's made
to this country she's proven that point
it is completely unacceptable for a 77y
old woman to do this is it is wrong it
is disordered it except for do Parton do
Parton she just she gets to break the
rules that's how it goes my favorite
comment on Friday is from Theo
Lombardi Theo Lombardi who writes I saw
you Michael I'm assuming flying home for
Thanksgiving I hope you had a great time
with your family oh that's that's
wonderful I'm glad that you you should
have come up and said hello though I
appre so I do appreciate it sometimes if
I'm with my family sometimes people
don't want to come you know chat but I
you know I always love chatting so uh
anyway that's really great you you might
have seen me I don't know which airport
you saw me at I did fly out of LaGuardia
and I want to
say if you happen to be flying out of
the Southwest terminal at LaGuardia
anytime soon you're so lucky the
Southwest terminal at LaGuardia deserves
a Michel and star the food in that
terminal look there's a beautiful water
display a light display it's really
comfortable even you're sitting with
your screaming kids and the food I had a
pastrami sandwich just a simple pastrami
Ry bread mustard from Juniors it was
excellent they had a Juniors right there
then I had some Stromboli that oh man
the Stromboli absolutely fabulous then
there was all this other stuff Hill
Country Barbecue was there it
was wow it was a great experience so I
hope you enjoyed that same experience
experence that I did speaking of female
singers an AI robot singer has taken the
World by storm this is a person is a
character created by
AI who then wrote a song you know the
computer wrote a song and then the
computer sang the song and the computer
talked about the song here she is Hello
World my name is Anna Indiana and I'm so
excited to share my music with you
here's my first song betrayed by this
town as an AI singer songwriter
everything from the key Tempo chord
progression Melody notes Rhythm lyrics
and my image and singing is
autogenerated using AI I hope you like
it
Cafe tea it's Saturday thinking about
all he's done to to
everyone this town is full of Broken
Dreams shattered hopes and Silent
screams somebody please
help
me the trade by this
town let's tear it all down we old just
destined to
fall I've lost it all
everyone's freaking
out the the libs you know the libs
anytime there's anything new they say oh
this is so exciting oh I love this new
thing even if it'll destroy civilization
that's great and the conservatives you
know what the conservatives is going to
destroy the where the West is Fallen
everything's gone to pot
okay for
starters I can't
wait I you're looking at this now if
you're watching this you're going to say
well the graphics aren't perfect the
mouth movements aren't quite right right
she still looks kind of like a little
bit like a cartoon yeah that's true but
don't worry 6 months from now this thing
is going to be perfect think about this
when the AI Imaging tools came out was
it six months ago a year ago at most
they couldn't do hands they couldn't
figure out how many fingers were on our
hands and now all of a sudden they can
do this so the the AI is improving at a
shockingly fast rate so they'll fix all
that stuff soon and then for me I think
look I spent a lot of my time I read the
news then I I interpret the news I think
okay what what does this what does this
news story really mean and then I
reference you know some ancient
philosophy maybe or some some medieval
historical event and I draw a parallel
and then I I say okay this is how I
should think about this new story and
then I write it down in a script that I
have to send to Mr Davies and Professor
Jacob and producer Danny and then we
pull clips and then I have to send then
they pull all the clips and then I come
in here and I sit here every morning for
like an hour and I do it you know and I
and I I I say what I think about it and
I gesticulate and I I uh have different
intonation and and I change my Cadence
and I'm not going to have to do any of
that I'm not going to have to do any of
that because a computer robot clone is
going to do all of that for me and then
I can move on to my true passion which
is selling quality cigars at competitive
prices okay that is great I can't I look
forward to that
that'll be wonderful but I my guess my
only fear is this that's the best case
scenario I would still probably keep
doing my show you know I still think I
can out Fox the computer probably at
least for a little bit longer but like
the libs the lib news presenters who
just read this the talking points that
they get in their emails the MSNBC
people the CNN people who you you can
play all their shows back toback they
all say the exact same thing in the
exact same wording it's AI should take
their jobs that's just creating
efficiency in the
market my fear here's where I'll flip to
the conservative side and talk about how
the West has fallen is the primary
application for this stuff is not going
to be music it's not going to be
political news shows and commentary and
lectures and it's not going to be any of
that you know what it's going to be the
primary application for this technology
is going to be three words weird sex
stuff we all know
it the moment that they perfect this
thing and the moment that they perfect
the sex robots and you know that's
coming the human race is going to cease
to exist because a ton of it's not even
it's going to be at weirdos by
definition but it's going to be a lot of
people who otherwise would not have
become weirdos but they're going to be
lured in by this they're going to
they're going to use this new
technology so differently from the way
that people are using pornography now
that it's it's going to be similar to
the distinction between a Playboy in the
1970s and internet pornography of the
last 20 years it's going to be so
tempting because it's the thing is going
to read your mind it's going to
construct an an image of a person that's
exactly to whatever preferences you have
and it's going to construct the language
model and all the other stuff and then
they're going to have sex robots and
then no one's going to get married
anymore and no one's going to have kids
and we're all going to go extinct and
that's unfortunate it's too bad but
speaking of babies and the future of
human
we have a little bit of good news here
which is that
32,000 more babies were born each year
for the last couple years thanks to the
Dos decision thanks to the overruling of
roie Wade and the subsequent abortion
banss in various
States 32,000 more babies per year this
is because of the state abortion bans
according to the Institute of labor
economics an average of 2.3% more babies
were born in states with abortion bands
compared to states without abortion
banss uh the group that saw the largest
increase in births were women in their
20s black women and Hispanic women so
that's a funny little line you know if
if the libs complain about this you you
can point out oh you're complaining that
more black babies are being born you
don't want all those black you want to
get rid of those black babies and you
want to kill them because you don't want
them to be walking around right because
you don't like the black people and then
they'll you know it probably won't work
it's similar to the Democrats are the
real racist line they they kind of Just
sh it off but it's a funny line in any
case there's a downside here the
downside is the number of abortions has
remained about the same the number of
abortions is actually up slightly
According to some measures and that's
because of of one new clinics opening
new abortion clinics you know
infanticide factories in the the
pro-abortion states it's also because of
the shift in technology most abortions
now are done with abortion pills so that
increase probably would have happened
anyway probably at a higher rate um so
we got to we got to deal with the
abortion pills issue but what does this
tell us tells us two things my my buddy
one of the great Twitter accounts udonia
pointed out that what this shows you is
that people were using abortion as
contraception because with an abortion B
you'd expect that number of new babies
born to be much much higher but what the
studies have concluded is that some
people who otherwise would have become
pregnant and then had abortions in
states where abortions were illegal they
just used other contraceptive methods to
prevent them getting pregnant in the
first place so even though we were told
for years that under no circumstances
are people using abortion as
contraception that obviously they were
doing that and in fact we I think we all
know people who have done that uh but
furthermore what this tells you and this
is much more important is the law is a
teacher politics is Downstream of
culture sure that's true there's there's
a lot of Truth to that it is at least as
true to say that culture is Downstream
of politics and the laws of teacher and
when you change the laws that creates
incentives and disincentives and creates
uh new kinds of behavior here and that's
not just an abstract academic concept
there are 32,000 human beings people
born every year so two years now we're
talking 64,000 human beings so far who
one day will look up and be able to say
I am alive today because of the courage
of five justices on the Supreme
Court to overrule roie Wade beautiful
thing beautiful thing the rest of the
show continues now you do not want to
miss it become a member use code NES
kwes at checkout for 2 months free on
all annual
[Music]
plans